[Music]
if we were to imagine what it would look
like to build a whole self
at mit
i think it starts with music
music is where you find your personal
expression
music is what opens new horizons
[Music]
i was very very excited when fred harris
contacted me to be a virtual visiting
artist at mit
[Music]
anat cohen is a treasure of a musician
she crosses many boundaries plays jazz
clarinet also saxophone got interested
in shorto shoto is a type of brazilian
music that grew up around rio de janeiro
in the early 20th century
i got to write an arrangement of a
brazilian showroom called shige
and they recorded it and performed it in
a virtual concert and i got to attend a
couple of rehearsals and work with the
students and it was a great experience
for for me and i hope by some of the
smiles i could see that those aha
moments were
really nice
[Music]
[Applause]
i could see how a student went from
point a to point b
how the progress was made how more
relaxed they were how they may have
taken my advice but also how they just
worked on their craft and achieved the
next level
it felt like a very inclusive process
what's most impactful is like the direct
feedback
we'd like play something and there would
be those tiny things that you might not
notice if you were just listening to a
recording and tried to emulate it
um
would you be like oh you know you're
like rushing a little bit you or or
she'd be like oh you know you have to
like introduce this like slightly
different swing that you're maybe not
used to playing
[Music]
i met all these incredible students of
mit and realizing how important music is
for them how
serious they are about it and how
dedicated they are and playing and keep
being involved and playing with other
musicians is important for
their existence
[Music]
you